[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis schönen guten abend und
herzlich willkommen alles wichtige vom
sport hat jede menge fußball schönen
guten abend knapp 200 länder ringen
derzeit um einen weg die erderwärmung zu
begrenzen
eines unserer ausführlichen themen heute
hohe erwartungen wenig hoffnung ist beim
klimagipfel in glasgow rufen politiker
zu größeren anstrengungen im kampf gegen
die klimakrise auf
debatte hinter den kulissen in der cdu
positionieren sich mögliche kandidaten
für die laschet nachfolge
und friedhofsbesuch an allerheiligen wir
schauen darauf wie sich die
bestattungskultur in deutschland
verändern
was sind die länder bereit zu tun um
eine klimakatastrophe noch abzuwenden
darum dreht es sich zurzeit beim
klimagipfel
die scheidende bundeskanzlerin hat dabei
für eine internationale co2 bepreisung
geworben gerade für inselstaaten und
besonders verletzliche länder sei ein
scheitern des gipfels ein zitat
todesurteil so un-generalsekretär
görisch aus glasgow diana zimmermann
die macht der bilder soll es richten im
konferenzzentrum in glasgow schauen die
regierungs und staatschefs bestürzt auf
szenen wie aus einem katastrophenfilm
tatsächlich ist es nur das was der
klimawandel schon jetzt an richtet die
erde ist heute im schnitt 1,1 grad
wärmer als im neunzehnten jahrhundert
momentan steuern wir auf mindestens 2,7
grad zu der gastgeber will dass es doch
noch ein happy end gibt sie sind in etwa
derselben situation wie james bond die
tragödie ist nur dass es kein film ist
sondern wirklich der tag des jüngsten
gerichts die uhr tickt zu auf diesen tag
und es ist eine minute vor zwölf wir
müssen und mit jetzt handeln
heute ist der tag der politischen
prominenz die hoffnung dass sich alle
gegenseitig ermuntern und anstacheln
mehr zu tun als bisher da wo die g-20
gestern in rom scheiterten soll nun ein
neuer anlauf genommen werden konkret
geht es um einen möglichst schnellen
ausstieg aus der kohle erst gestern war
die g-20 damit gescheitert das datum für
co2 neutralität auf 2.050 festzulegen
angela merkel hat ihre erste
klimakonferenz vor 26 jahren geleitet
glasgow ist ihre letzte
wir wissen dass insbesondere weise die
industrieländer verantwortung tragen und
das betrifft natürlich auch die
bundesrepublik deutschland
deshalb haben wir unsere klimaziele noch
einmal verschärft wir wollen bis 2045
klimaneutral sein
doch dass es insgesamt nicht reichen
wird dass die konferenz viel
wohlklingendes und wenig substanz bringt
befürchten delegierte und aktivisten
zumal es um manchen staatschef gibt er
sich nicht mal die mühe gemacht hat
guten willen auch nur zu demonstrieren
weder regen noch wladimir putin sind
nach glasgow gekommen
grund für die erderwärmung ist die
steigende konzentration von co2 in der
atmosphäre
knapp 11 milliarden tonnen kohlendioxid
entstehen jährlich vor allem durch
fossile brennstoffe rund die hälfte geht
in die atmosphäre
der rest wird in unseren meeren und
wäldern gebunden sowie im
amazonas-regenwald aber das riesige
ökosystem schrumpft durch raubbau brände
und steigende temperaturen
christoph pirat hat sich vor ort ein
bild gemacht im dorf der tattoo you im
amazonas-regenwald scheint das
schottische glasgow unendlich weit weg
doch die frontlinie im kampf gegen den
klimawandel läuft mitten durch die
indigenen dörfer brasiliens sie sind es
die regelmäßig den holzfällern und gold
schürfen entgegentreten müssen und die
lage wird immer gefährlicher
seit präsident wollte naro sein amt
angetreten hat dem anführer der tour
bleibt nur ein appell an die mächtigen
der welt
sie sollten der brasilianischen
regierung sagen dass sie ihre politik
ändern sollen es passieren hier zurzeit
dinge die in 50 jahren nicht passiert
sind
wie ernst die lage ist hat jüngst eine
groß angelegte studie belegt sie zeigt
dass das ökosystem regenwald gibt schon
jetzt gibt der wald teilweise mehr co2
ab als er aufnimmt nichts geringeres als
der anfang vom ende warnt die leitende
forscherin
jedes jahr gibt es weniger bäume die
regen produzieren und damit die
temperatur senken und hier schlimmer die
bedingungen desto weniger co2 kann der
bald aufnehmen und so wird er sogar zu
einer co2 quelle
ein ökologischer teufelskreis der fast
nur noch in den gebieten der indigenen
völker durchbrochen werden kann die
zerstörung des regenwaldes hat nicht
erst mit präsident portion euro begonnen
darunter seiner regierung erreicht der
raubbau neue dimensionen die indigenen
völker die hier in ihren gebieten gegen
die abholzung kämpfen fühlen sich mehr
und mehr allein gelassen nur ein
sofortiger stopp der abholzung kann das
endgültige kippen des ökosystems
regenwald noch verhindern darin sind
sich indigene und wissenschaftler einig
beispiel brasilien zeigt die massiven
folgen der klimakrise in glasgow
verfolgt unserer umwelt experte volker
angres die weltklimakonferenz volker
gibt es denn beim gipfel auch so etwas
wie ein silberstreif am horizont
ja so klein bisschen kann man schon
sagen indien zum beispiel hat heute
angekündigt bis 2070 klimaneutral zu
werden das ist noch lange hin aber
indien verbrennt eben auch sehr viel
kohle ich glaube ganz ganz wichtig ist
dass es mir immer mehr bilaterale
kooperationen gibt also vereinbarung
zwischen länder wie man sich gegenseitig
beim klimaschutz helfen kann deutschland
die usa und großbritannien werden zum
beispiel mit südafrika zusammenarbeiten
um dort den kohleausstieg hinzubekommen
das ist ein riesiges projekt der in
südafrika hat 90 prozent kohle strom im
netz es wird viele weitere kooperationen
geben eine andere die existiert schon
mit schily da ist deutschland auch
beteiligt da geht es um ein großes
sonnenkraftwerk in der atacama wüste und
dergleichen mehr ich habe so ein
bisschen den eindruck dass neben der
großen konferenz die natürlich zunächst
einmal das klimaabkommen von paris stück
für stück paragraf für paragraf
abarbeiten muss das dann eben sich so
eine art zweite ebene bildet wo immer
mehr länder indirekten absprachen
miteinander versuchen die
klimaproblematik in den griff zu
bekommen und das funktioniert natürlich
viel besser als wenn man 190 staaten am
ende der konferenz einstimmig zu einem
beschluss führen muss also einige
versuchung voranzugehen vielen dank für
diese einschätzung volker anders
wer zahlt am ende für die klimakrise
eine der fragen im zdf- heute live mit
der freude ist verfügte aktivistin luisa
neubauer direkt im anschluss an diese
sendung auf youtube facebook und der
zdf- heute- app dort finden sie auch
jede menge grafiken und daten zur
erderwärmung
wie die cdu mit der klimakrise künftig
umgehen will auch das hängt davon ab wie
sie sich inhaltlich und personell neu
aufstellt wer folgt auf parteichef armin
laschet die basis will da mitreden
morgen berät die parteiführung über das
prozedere und heute gab es hinter den
kulissen schon mal etwas bewegung bei
der frage wer seinen hut in den ring
wirft das ganze beobachtet für uns theo
koll theo wer bringt sich in der cdu
denn da wie in stellung nun friedrich
merz und norbert röttgen liegen
jedenfalls in der gunst der mitglieder
vorn aber nicht so eindeutig dass eine
eine klare mehrheit hätte und auch
deshalb verdichten sich die gerüchte
dass beide an team lösungen arbeiten es
geht ja jetzt zum ersten mal in der
geschichte der cdu darum eine mehrheit
der 400.000 mitglieder hinter sich zu
bringen und für mögliche teambildung ist
die gerade gelaufen der klausur der cdu
landesgruppe nordrhein-westfalen bestens
geeignet denn alle bisher genannten
bewerber möglichen bewerber sind männer
aus nordrhein westfalen bei den
kandidaten beziehungsweise den teams
geht es aber nicht nur am körper sondern
auch um die künftige ausrichtung der
partei also wie konservativ liberal will
die cdu künftig sein morgen werden die
gremien hier in berlin über das
wahlverfahren entscheiden man will
versuchen noch vor weihnachten fertig zu
sein denn schon im frühjahr stehen dann
drei wichtige landtagswahlen an wo die
cdu bisher jedenfalls die regierungschef
stellt vielen dank theo
corona da geht der anstieg der
neuinfektionen
ungebremst weiter auch die sieben tage
incident steigt seit wochen anfang
oktober lag sie noch bei gut 64 heute
bei fast
155 diese entwicklung zeigt sich
inzwischen auch auf den
intensivstationen
dort liegen jetzt wieder mehr als 2000
kurve patientinnen und patienten und in
dieser situation gebe es auch noch einen
bedrohlichen mangel an fachkräften im
gesundheitswesen so ärztepräsident
reinhardt beim deutschen ärztetag
erwarte vor einem kollaps des systems
währenddessen geht die diskussion um
auffrischungsimpfungen weiter auch die
diskussion darüber ob die impfzentren
wieder eröffnet werden sollten was heute
der bundesgesundheitsminister gefordert
mehrere länder lehnen das aber ab britta
spiekermann
heute deutsche ärztetag das 125 treffen
diesmal in berlin auch zur aktuellen
corona lage minister sparen hatte
gefordert booster für alle der ärztetag
kontert dafür gebe es keine
wissenschaftliche evidenz jetzt helfe
kein aktionismus sondern sortiertes
vorgehen leitlinie sei die empfehlung
der ständigen impfkommission
alle älteren als 70 sollten jetzt eine
auffrischung vorbehalten wenn die sechs
monate ihre zweite impfung um sind und
diejenigen die johnson & johnson nur
einmal erhalten haben sollten auf
auffrischungen und diejenigen die
besonders wohlhabende bestimmten
erkrankungen und personal was in pflege
und altenpflege arbeitet ärztinnen und
ärzte bereiten sich vor auf noch
gefüllte hre praxen als ohnehin schon im
herbst und winter unterstützung sei
jetzt notwendig wir bieten
beispielsweise in unserer ländlichen
praxis mindestens dreimal pro woche
impftermine halbtags an die auslastung
ist gut die nachfrage ist gut im zentrum
haben uns entlastet und würden uns jetzt
auch weiterhin absolut entlasten wie
viele andere auch schloss dieses
impfzentrum in hannover ende september
nun könnten die zentren die noch im
standby modus sind wieder öffnen
zumindest fordert dass der noch
geschäftsführende
bundesgesundheitsminister nach einem
positiven fall in seiner familie meldete
sich heute sachsens ministerpräsident
aus der quarantäne kretzschmar zeigte
sich besorgt über die hohe belastung der
kliniken schon morgen ein krisentreffen
das
zurück nach berlin die botschaft hier an
ärztinnen und ärzte die booster impfung
ist wichtig allerdings die älteren
zuerst
auch in österreich geht die korona kurve
steil nach oben deshalb müssen sich
jetzt dort fast alle beschäftigten an
die 3g regel halten hilft genesen oder
getestet sonst drohen empfindliche
geldstrafen
die regierung erhofft sich davon schwung
für die impfkampagne bei unserem
nachbarn sind nur 63 prozent der
menschen vollständig geimpft
auch in deutschland ändert sich ab heute
etwas für viele ungeimpfte beschäftigte
nämlich für die die sich impfen lassen
könnten es aber nicht tun für die geld
wenn sie kontakt mit einem infizierten
hatten oder aus einem hochrisiko gebiet
kommen und deshalb in quarantäne müssen
danach startet der staat dem arbeitgeber
für sie keine lohnfortzahlung mehr das
heißt im ernstfall bekommen den
mitarbeitenden dann für die
quarantänezeit keinen lohn nicola
albrecht berichtet bei firma grädler in
brandenburg hält man nichts von dem
neuen gesetz das unternehmen für
fördertechnik wurde schon mehrfach als
arbeitgeber mit besonders
vertrauensvolle arbeitsplatzkultur
ausgezeichnet in sensiblen zeiten wolle
er den betriebsfrieden nicht gefährden
argumentiert geschäftsführer frank
raether im ernstfall zahle er
ungeimpften mitarbeitern in quarantäne
den lohn aus der firmenkasse
geht immer um die eigenverantwortung und
ich als arbeitgeber wurde nie druck auf
meine mitarbeiter
ausführen wollen ohne impfung kein geld
diese regelung gilt ab sofort für alle
ungeimpften die als kontaktperson eines
infizierten in quarantäne müssen oder
aber weil sie aus einem hochrisiko
gebiet zurückkehren dann fällt auch der
datenschutz was den impfstatus betrifft
wenn jemand in quarantäne gehen muss
kann der arbeitgeber ab sofort erfragen
ob diese person geimpft ist und ist sie
nicht geimpft kann der arbeitgeber sagen
ich zahle keinen lohn weiter wichtig
aber auch wer an corona erkrankt erhält
lohnfortzahlungen den druck auf
ungeimpfte erhöhen darum geht es doch
diese debatte spaltet gesellschaft und
politik viele arbeitgeberverbände
verteidigen das gesetz das kann nicht
richtig sein dass wie man sagt ich lehne
es ab ich habe die möglichkeit mich
kostenlos immunisieren zu lassen tut das
nicht und bin dann gleichwohl halte ich
die hand auf und sage wenn sich daraus
nachteile geben muss dass die
gesellschaft tragen und so wird weiter
um maßnahmen gerungen mitten in der
vierten welle
bei den ermittlungen gegen den
verschwörungs ideologen atilla hält man
geht berlin staatsanwaltschaft von einem
maulwurf in den eigenen reihen aus einer
angestellten aus der it abteilung der
behörde wurde inzwischen fristlos
gekündigt gegen hildmann er ging im
februar haftbefehl wegen volksverhetzung
und des verdachts der öffentlichen
aufforderung zu straftaten
laut staatsanwaltschaft reiste die
justizangestellte zu hält man in die
türkei um ihn mit informationen zu
versorgen
zu einem fall der zunächst nach einem
tragischen unfall aussah vor drei tagen
vor ein auto in nordhessen in eine
schülergruppe ein mädchen starb zwei
weitere wurden verletzt jetzt hat die
polizei den verdacht der fahrer könnte
vorsätzlich gehandelt haben sein wagen
hatte die kinder auf einem gehweg vor
einer kita erfasst die polizei vermutet
dass der 30 jährige psychisch kranke ist
nun wird wegen mordes ermittelt
katholikinnen und katholiken in
deutschland feiern heute alle heiligen
in den fünf katholisch geprägten
bundesländern ist dies ein gesetzlicher
feiertag in vielen gemeinden wird der
toten gedacht und die gräber werden
gesegnet aber der bevorzugte platz für
die ewige ruhe ist nicht mehr unbedingt
die klassische grabstätte immer mehr
deutsche wünschen sich eine
feuerbestattung und eine beisetzung in
einem urnengrab petra otto
es ist ein ort nicht nur der trauer und
des sich erinnern der friedhof der
gehört den lebenden und deshalb muss er
so sein wie sie ihn sich wünschen findet
der friedhof amtsleiter matthäus vogel
was sie auf dem friedhof sehen ist das
abbild unserer gesellschaft oder unseres
gesellschaftlichen denkens die menschen
wollen dem natur gedanken rechnung
tragen mehr verantwortung für die natur
übernehmen und nachhaltig handeln kleine
grabsteine gehauen aus alten großen
vorhandenes wiederverwendet nicht
importiert aus china oder indien hier in
karlsruhe haben sie urnengräber inseln
angelegt rund um eine neu gepflanzten
baum fast alle gräber sind schon
reserviert ich kann mich noch gut
erinnern vor 20 30 jahren da haben die
menschen die ein grab angepachtet oder
angemeldet haben sich überlegt wo steht
ein baum kann ich weit genug weg damit
ich keine blätter habe damit ich keinen
schattenwurf habe mittlerweile
zurückgekehrt unter einem baum begraben
zu sein diese vorstellung gefällt mehr
menschen auf dem friedhof selbst oder
auch außerhalb in sogenannten
bestattungs wäldern in denen die natur
die grabpflege übernimmt weg von der
strengen ordnung von der norm trotzdem
würde folgen die gräber sie müssen
einfach zu den menschen passen
so und jetzt kommen wir zum sport
borussia mönchengladbach hat im moment
ja einen richtig guten lauf oder zwei
siege in fünf tagen kann sich sehen
lassen nach dem glanzvollen 5 0
pokaltriumph liegen bayern münchen legte
gladbach gestern in der bundesliga nach
zwei 2 1 erfolg gegen den vfl bochum
allerdings mussten die borussen gegen
den aufsteiger in der schlussphase noch
mal richtig zittern dass pantelic kurz
vor abpfiff nicht zum 2 2 trifft
enttäuscht die bochumer zunächst aber
dass bis zum abpfiff ein unentschieden
in der luft liegt stärkt beim neuling
den glauben an den klassenerhalt werden
natürlich wollte gerne was mitgenommen
aber im großen und ganzen wenn wir so
auftreten bin ich guter dinge dass wir
auch die nötigen punkte holen gladbach
gestern aber insbesondere in der ersten
hälfte zu stark leer in der zwölften
minute mit dem 1 0 und noch vor der
pause erhöht hofmann dank erstklassiger
schusstechnik zum 20 nach dem wechsel
imponiert dann aber auch bochum dani
blums fantastischer freistoß zum 2 2 1
lässt den aufsteiger noch mal hoffen es
bleibt dann aber beim verdienten sieg
der borussia
und alle tore von allen partien des
zehnten spieltages können sie sich bei
uns noch mal ganz in ruhe anschauen wie
immer online zusammengefasst auf zdf
heute und in der zdf- heute- app so
bleiben sie dann auch immer am ball
andrea petkovic hat ihr auftaktmatch
beim billie jean king cup gegen marke
davosa war in prag 1 zu 6 und 3 6
verloren deutschland liegt damit nach
dem ersten von zwei einzeln und einem
doppel null zu eins gegen tschechien
zurück in diesem wichtigsten mannschafts
wettbewerb des frauentennis
andrea petkovic hatte sich ihr einzel
gegen die in der weltrangliste 41 plätze
besser notierte marketa wollen
sicherlich ganz anders vorgestellt
doch von beginn an dominierte die 22
jährige tschechin die begegnung fast
nach belieben
nach 80 minuten stand das ergebnis schon
fest mit 6 1 und 6 3 gewann war und
rousseau war gegen andrea petkovic
überraschend deutlich und sicherte
tschechien damit die 1 0-führung gegen
das deutsche team
zweites match dann mit angelique kerber
das was vom sport
beim wetter ist wieder regen ein thema
mehr dazu gleich von özden terli das
heute-journal können sie um 21 auf 140
sehen mit claus kleber das ganze team
und ich sagen auf wiedersehen machen sie
es gut
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter kräftiger regen
kommt im süden deutschlands auf und der
zieht sich dann auch weiter nach
nordosten das hat mit diesem tiefe zu
tun und von westen her gelangt kühlere
luft zu uns und so wird es in den
nächsten tagen spürbar kühler werden
schauen wir die nachts zu und da gibt es
im südosten regen der ist kräftig und
auch nach osten hin verlagert sich
langsam nach norden und ganz im
südwesten gibt es auch etwas regen das
nicht so viel sonst erst einmal trocken
temperaturen dazu die tiefsten werte am
alpenrand bei drei grad es ist der
kälteste ort ansonsten liege bei 4 bis 8
grad morgen tagesverlauf weiterer regen
vor allem im süd osten lockert dann
allmählich auf und auch im osten regen
zum nachmittag bilden sich von westen
her erneut schauer ganz im norden da
zeigt sich sogar die sonne und die
temperaturen dazu mit höchsten werten
zwischen sieben und zwölf grad ist es
nicht mehr so mit vier am wochenende
schauen wir auf die nächsten tage am
mittwoch kommt dann kommen neue schauer
auf ansonsten nach osten erst mal
trocken bei sechs bis zwölf grad und
danach wird es spürbar kühler bei
höchsttemperaturen von vier bis elf grad
ein schöner abend